this video is sponsored by squarespace
what's going on people today we're
explaining how the timeline of attack on
titan would have completely changed if
armin inherited the armored titan as we
know back in season 3 there was a time
when the scouts had captured both reiner
and bertolt but thanks to ryan's
indestructible plot armor he was the one
that was saved while his friend was left
behind in this video we're exploring how
things would have played out if the
situation was reversed with rhino being
the one who was eaten and beltop being
the one who was saved by peak before we
get into it though this video is the
first half of a two-part series so don't
forget to colossal smash that sub button
so you don't miss the final part when it
comes out
okay so the new timeline begins in the
year 850 with the warriors arriving back
home having just been beaten by the
scouts in the original series this was
the time period when the middle eastern
alliance declared war against mali since
they figured the warriors were
vulnerable having just lost their female
and colossal titans however in this
alternate timeline where bertolt
survived they never would have declared
war in the first place and the reason
for this is pretty simple
in the world of attack on titan bertolt
is the closest thing to a nuclear weapon
that exists and despite all the
anti-titan tech enemy nations still
don't have anything that could deal with
him as a very quick example of what i
mean let's imagine for a second that
bertolt was there during the battle of
forslava in the anime we saw how the
beast and armor titans struggled to get
the job done and were nearly killed
whereas bertolt by himself could have
single-handedly blown up the middle
eastern fleet while also crushing fort
slava with his colossal foot to put it
simply the difference in power between
him and the other warriors is so massive
that no country would be dumb enough to
declare war against mali while he's
still alive as a result in this new
timeline the middle eastern war never
happened which drastically changes how
the military reacts to losing two of
their titan shifters for a start i think
it's highly likely that beltop would
argue they need to return to the island
since he'd want to save annie and reiner
as quickly as possible remember marley
didn't know that parodies had the fluid
to turn armin into a titan so as far as
they're aware rhino annie could
genuinely both still be alive that's why
berta would be desperate to move quickly
before something happens but i reckon
commander mcgowan would be 50 50 about
the whole thing on one hand he'd agree
that they should try to get their
missing warriors back but on flipside
there's a risk that trying to do this
could result in even more people being
killed if marley continues to lose more
and more shifters then it's only a
matter of time until they lose their
dominant position in the world so he'd
be hesitant for any of them to go back
however this is the moment where zeke
would chip in as he'd remind the
commander that right now the island is
more exposed than any time in the past
five years
while it is true that parodies
technically won the battle in
shiganchina they lost virtually the
entire survey core in the process which
everyone knows are their strongest
fighters with only a handful of scouts
remaining there's no way they'd be able
to hold back the warriors a second time
especially if marley attacks sooner
rather than later zeke would also try to
scare everyone by claiming that they
need to capture the founder before he
gains a better understanding of his
abilities otherwise they might get
trampled by the rumbling of course that
part would be a bluff since zeke knows
that aaron can't use the founder without
a titan of royal blood but obviously no
one in mali is aware of that besides him
after hearing all this it's virtually
guaranteed that mcgath would reluctantly
agree to return to paradise but first
he'd want to gather some intel before
launching a full-scale invasion to be
specific what they need to know is
eren's location annie and ryan's
location and how the malian army can
avoid the threat of pure titans the
answer to those questions will determine
what their strategy is going to be and
to acquire this intel they need to send
a small team to infiltrate the island
for their own personal reasons zeke and
bertolt would definitely volunteer
themselves to join this mission but
mcgath would order bertolt to stay
behind partly because molly needs the
colossal as a deterrent but also because
it's hard for berto to go undercover
when literally everyone knows his face
in the end the warriors chosen to
infiltrate parodies would be zeke and
peak and their instructions would be to
learn what they can and return to the
harbor within three weeks regardless of
what happens if neither of them makes it
back within this time period then the
general will assume they've been
captured by the scouts meaning the
warriors have a solid deadline to return
by unlike the original mission five
years ago
a few nights later zeke and peak would
then be brought to the island by ship
disguised in clothes that more easily
allow them to blend in with society
thanks to this disguise they're easily
able to sneak into tross district
without any problems but it wouldn't
take them long to realize that
something's wrong all across the city
the mood would be completely unusual and
that's because in the short time since
the warriors were last here everyone has
learned the truth about the outside
world the findings from grisha's books
were published in newspapers and
bulletins all across the country and
people would still be coming to terms
with the idea that there are humans
outside the walls trying to invade them
in pete's case i imagine that she'd be
concerned about this development because
if the iron suspects that marley is
planning to invade them soon then the
military police might be on the lookout
for undercover spies given that they
don't have id it's possible they could
be questioned but zeke would just brush
it off and tell her not to worry about
it in his own mind it's actually a good
thing that aaron now has a concept of
humanity outside the walls since this
will make it easier to convince his
brother of the need for the
euthanization plan before we get into
that though over the next three weeks
the malian army would continue to make
preparations for a full-scale invasion
with bertolt being an advisor due to his
extensive knowledge of the island's
capabilities at the same time zeke and
peak would be completing their mission
and traveling deeper into the walls and
after finally tracking down eren they'd
watch on from a distance as he shows
armin how to fight with the armored
titan for the two warriors this would be
confirmation that paradise is somehow
producing titan transformation serum and
with reina being dead they spent their
last few days on the island searching
for any sign of annie gradually the
search would bring them to stowas where
they overhear a rumor from some
civilians that she's being held at
military police hq with that bit of info
peek would now be more than ready to
return back home but zeke would argue
that he should stay behind to watch over
the female titan his argument would be
that they have no idea why annie is
still alive even though ryan has been
eaten and his theory is that parodies
must be in the process of selecting
female titan candidates if the warriors
leave now then there's a small chance
annie might be eaten by the time they
get back so he'd volunteer to stay in
stowas for two additional days this
would give peak time to get back to mali
and report everything they've discovered
and in a couple days when the military
arrives zeke agrees to meet them at the
harbour with the latest info about
annie's condition despite not fully
trusting the worst coming out of his
mouth at the end of the day zeke is
still the warchief which means that
other warriors generally follow what he
says unless they have a passionate
reason not to that's why pique would
make her way back to mali overnight and
the following day she'd explained the
intel to magath porco and the rest of
the team in particular berto would be
almost inconsolable after hearing about
reina's death especially because armin
is the person who ate him in bertot's
head it was his failure to kill armin
that directly led to his best friend
being eaten but interestingly i think
this guilt would make him more
determined to at least rescue annie
moving on with peak's intel the military
would finalize their plan to capture the
founding titan and the next day they'd
arrive at the harbour where zeke is
supposed to be however as the morning
drags on there'd be no sign of the beast
titan anywhere gradually causing the
warriors to wonder if something happened
to the warchief what they wouldn't know
is that everything is coming together
exactly the way he contended but to
explain how we first need to look back
at the original timeline in the main
timeline it was pretty clear that zeke
had a lot of things he wanted to say to
aaron but due to the middle eastern war
the only way he could communicate was
through messengers like yelena and
azmobito in this alternate reality
though the scenario was flipped around
with zeke having this chance to be on
the island by himself and personally
talk to his brother of course the
problem here is that aaron perceives him
as the enemy for obvious reasons so the
challenge physique is getting aaron to
trust him in a short space of time to
accomplish this what he needs to do is
number one prove that he's not a threat
and number two create a situation where
the scouts have no choice but to rely on
him the first part of this plan began
the night peak arrived back in mali as
this is when the beast titan willingly
surrendered himself in stowas to
demonstrate he doesn't mean the island
any harm zeke knew that a stunt like
this would send shock waves across
parodies but more importantly would also
allow him to speak to the right people
just as planned within 10 hours or so
historia aaron and other vips would all
arrive in the district for an emergency
trial as they'd interrogate him to find
out his true motivations as the trial
goes on he'd give a speech similar to
the one he gave kyomi and the manga in
which he explains to everyone that he's
actually been an elden restorationist
this whole time in his words everything
he's done and said up until now was to
gain the trust of the mali military but
behind their backs he's been making
moves to save the alien people zeke
would then claim that the reason he
surrendered himself is because the
warriors plan to imminently wipe out the
island and only he knows the secret to
stop it zachary would respond by asking
zeke what the secret is but the beast
would turn directly to his younger
brother and demand that he can only
reveal this knowledge in private to eren
following that the military higher-ups
would hold crisis talks on what to do
next as they debate whether zeke's
warning should be taken seriously in one
sense it is accurate that they were
expecting this to happen in the near
future and it's not surprising that a
large nation like mali would have the
resources to attack so soon that being
said there's a possibility that zeke
might be lying so they give into his
request which would potentially put the
founding titan at risk at some point
during the conversation armin would
propose that maybe zeke is telling the
truth since if the beast titan's goal
was really to kill or capture aaron then
he could have simply stayed undercover
on the island and attacked when they
weren't expecting it the fact he
willingly turned himself in indicates
that there's something else going on
since being locked underground isn't a
great move if he wanted to steal the
coordinate while most people wouldn't
buy into army's line of thinking i think
commander hanji would be the one person
to take it seriously and later that
night they'd paid a visit to zeke in his
cell there the commander would try to
find out what exactly this grand plan is
that can apparently save the island but
the beast titan wouldn't say a thing
since he knows marley are arriving the
next day his prediction is that once he
doesn't show up at the harbour the
military will assume that something
might have happened to either him or
annie meaning it's guaranteed the
warriors will head to stowas when that
happens parodies simply won't have the
firepower to fight back putting them in
a desperate situation where they'll have
to give in to zeke's demands
flashing forward to the present day
aaron armand and mikasa would sit down
for a chat where they'd be discussing
the prospect of fighting the warriors a
second time among the scouts morale
would be pretty low at this point seeing
as there were hardly any of them left
and armin would start to have serious
survivor's guilt as he believed that
they'd need irvine's leadership in a
crisis like this however aaron tries to
cheer him up by confessing that he knows
a way to win even without the commander
and it all comes down to the founding
titan for the first time ever aaron
would reveal his theory that he can
activate the coordinate by touching a
titan of royal blood but of course he
never told anyone about this since he
didn't want historia to be in danger the
reason he tells his friends now is
because he thinks it could be the secret
plan that zeke was referring to meaning
that the beast titan really might be on
their side mikasa would likely argue
that they should tell someone about this
but aaron would likely be hesitant since
if the secret gets out then there's no
telling what exactly the government will
do to historia before they decide what
they should do next a large earthquake
would rock stoic district with injured
civilians screaming and running for
their lives meanwhile across the rest of
the island malian forces would descend
upon nearly every major city including
trust district orvoo district and even
the royal capital it's important for us
to remember that mali's international
reputation was damaged by them losing
insurgency and so the general's plan is
to remind the world how powerful they
are by crushing parodies in a single day
with over a million soldiers in total
they have way more than enough to target
their major locations on the island
while in stow west the colossal titan
demonstrates his destructive power
bertolt aggressively stomps through the
district as a horrified aaron watches on
and considering what happened in
shigachina a month ago he'd be uncertain
what he can even do in this situation at
the same time pique and porker would be
using this distraction from bertolt to
infiltrate military police hq where they
come face to face with their fellow
warrior for the first time in 5 years
sadly for them they wouldn't be able to
find any sign of zeke but the beast
titan would be safely in his underground
cell feeling pretty good about himself
since it's only a matter of time until
he finally gets that heart to heart with
aaron
anyhow before we wrap up today's video i
did want to take a moment to thank
today's sponsor squarespace if you're
looking for a fast easy and affordable
way to create a professional looking
website which is something i've been
looking to do since starting my channel
then squarespace is definitely right for
you with so many different platforms and
softwares for things like audience
insights and blogging tools i know i
personally get overwhelmed with where to
even start but with squarespace you can
do all of these things in one easy to
use platform if you head over to
squarespace.com you can have access to a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch you can go to squarespace.com
turtlequirk to save 10 of your first
purchase of a website or domain with
that said thanks for watching and thanks
again to squarespace for sponsoring
today's video